[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert König
für den Sport na mit Fußball natürlich
aus Australien und Neuseeland schauen
wir auf den Nachrichtenthemen von heute
Appell an den Kreml die Vereinten
Nationen drängen Russland zu einem neuen
getreideabkommen auch China ruft dazu
auf
Spanien vor der Richtungswahl eine
Koalition aus konservativen und
rechtsextremen will die regierenden
Sozialisten ablösen
und zwischen Diversität und Angriffen
Berlin feiert den Christopher Street Day
doch die Gewalt gegen queere Menschen
nimmt zu
[Musik]
selbst Peking macht jetzt Druck auf
Russland im UN-Sicherheitsrat hat China
mit mehreren Ländern den Kreml dazu
aufgerufen ukrainische Getreideexporte
übers Schwarze Meer wieder zuzulassen um
eine weltweite Ernährungskrise zu
verhindern doch bislang bombardiert
Moskau weiter ukrainische Häfen und
Getreidevorräte Axel Konrad
die Raketen wurden abgefeuert von
Schiffen im Schwarzen Meer ganz gezielt
auf diesen landwirtschaftlichen Betrieb
bei Odessa
es brannte feuerwehr und Rettungskräfte
kamen und dann der zweite luft-
zwei Personen werden durch Glassplitter
verletzt 100 Tonnen Erbsen und 20 Tonnen
Gerste sind vernichtet Gebäude und
Fahrzeuge zerstört
ich weiß nicht wie wir das alles wieder
aufbauen können aber wir haben
entschieden wir machen es auf eigene
Faust wir werden nicht nach dem Start
rufen wir sind doch nicht die einzigen
die Verluste haben
trotz Raketen und vermieten Feldern die
Ernte war gut dieses Jahr in der Ukraine
aber die kommt die Ware jetzt in die
Welt nach dem Russland aus dem
getreideabkommen ausgestiegen ist eine
weltweite Nahrungsmittelkrise droht und
so macht selbst der Enge russische
Verbündete China Druck auf Moskau wohl
auch weil China mit Abstand der größte
Abnehmer von ukrainischem Getreide ist
die Lieferungen müssten rasch wieder
möglich gemacht werden Ziel sein die
internationale Ernährungssicherheit zu
erhalten und die Nahrungsmittelkrise
insbesondere in den Entwicklungsländern
so der chinesische Abgesandte bei der UN
damit das Getreide nicht in den Silos
verrottet sucht die Ukraine nach
alternativen Exportmöglichkeiten die
Idee des zuständigen Ministers helfen in
ganz Europa inklusive Deutschlands
könnten genutzt werden wenn es
finanzielle Hilfe bei den hohen
Transportkosten gibt
wir brauchen spezielle Kompensationen
wenn wir das möglich machen wenn die
Europäische Union bereit ist das zu
diskutieren dann werden wir das Problem
lösen
[Musik]
und beim Kriegsgeschehen lassen diese
beiden Nachrichten aufhorchen den
Einsatz ukrainischer Streubomben
recherchierten bei saporisha offenbar
russische Journalisten und wurden genau
von diesen getroffen dieser Reporter
soll getötet worden sein drei weitere
verletzt
dann wieder ein Angriff auf der Grimm
durch ukrainische Drohnen der zuständige
von Moskau eingesetzte
Munitionslager sei getroffen worden die
Menschen im Umkreis von fünf Kilometern
werden evakuiert
der russische Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine überschattet auch das Treffen
der G20 Energieminister im indischen Goa
Indien weigert sich bislang Russland für
den Angriff zu verurteilen auch Russland
gehört zu den G20 und blockiert mit
anderen Ländern eine Einigung über mehr
Tempo beim Ausbau erneuerbarer Energie
Karl Hinterleitner über die schwierige
Gemengelage in Goa
energiepolitisch war es ein Gipfel der
Unverbindlichkeiten geopolitisch war es
aber vor allem ein Gipfel der Probleme
mit Russland Robert Habeck zeigte sich
über das russische Auftreten bei den
giz20 entsetzt jeder versucht der
Verständigung sei sinnlos gewesen
[Musik]
im russischen stellvertretenden
energieministers eine völlige Verkennung
der Wirklichkeit
ausgesprochen wurde er hat die
Energiekrise auf die Finanzkrise des
Jahres 2008 zurückgeführt als wäre das
jetzt nur eine Reaktion darauf also das
ist mit alternativen Fakten freundlich
beschrieben es ist einfach eine völlig
verdrehte Welt Sicht doch auch bei
potenziellen Freunden ist die Welt sich
nicht leicht der deutschen habichtsreise
nach Indien sollte die Partnerschaft
vertiefen doch Indien ist in Sachen
Russland nicht im Lager des Westens bei
den Beziehungen gibt es ähnliche
Probleme wie hier beim G20 manche Länder
weigern sich den russischen
Angriffskrieg zu verurteilen z.B weil
sie aus Rohstoff Lieferungen aus
Russland angewiesen sind Robert Habeck
Quartier deutlicher und Schafe Worte
doch viele schließen sich dem nicht an
bei potentiellen Partnern eine
grundsätzlich andere Sicht auf die Dinge
und das überschattet den Gipfel
am Ende waren es Verhandlungen ohne
konkrete Resultate aber mit erheblichen
Differenzen das Wichtigste war wohl
überhaupt im Gespräch zu bleiben
bei der Wahl in Spanien morgen könnte es
im Land einen Rechtsruck geben bislang
regiert der Sozialist Petrus Sanchez mit
einer koali in einer Koalition mit den
Linkspopulisten doch viele Umfragen
sehen die konservative partido populare
Form allerdings wohl nicht weit genug um
allein zu regieren deswegen ist jetzt
die große Frage ob sich die
Konservativen auf eine Koalition mit der
rechtsextremen vox-partei einlassen aus
Madrid Thomas Walde
am Tag vor der Stimmabgabe ist der
Wahlkampf in Spanien traditionell
beendet
Premierminister Sanchez strampelte sich
bis zuletzt ab und postete heute diese
Bilder kurz zuvor hatte der Sozialist in
den letzten Umfragen zurück lag ein
letztes Mal versucht seine Anhänger zu
mobilisieren mit der Angst vor einem
Rechtsrucks gewinnen wir die Wahl um die
rechte und die extreme Rechte zu stoppen
der Fortschritt wird gewinnen der
Rückschritt wird verlieren
das Ziel vor allem auf die rechts außen
von VOX eine Partei mit
antifeministischen migrationsfeindlichen
und nationalistischen Positionen
Zivilisation des Kreuzes Nein zu
islamistischer Gewalt ja zur nationalen
Souveränität und Nein zu den
globalistischen Bürokraten
VOX regiert in einigen Regionen bereits
mit der Volkspartei PP nun zeigt sich
VOX bereit den Kandidaten der PP Alberto
feho zum Premierminister zu machen gegen
eine Regierungsbeteiligung Ferro der
heute in seiner Nachbarschaft einkaufte
sagte bis zuletzt nichts zu einer
Koalition mit den Rechtsaußen um sich
nicht angreifbar zu machen
ich will dass wir die Spannungen der
vergangenen fünf Jahre unter Sanchez
hinter uns lassen ich biete an die
Blockade zwischen den Blöcken in Spanien
zu überwinden
Unsicherheit herrscht über die
Wahlbeteiligung weil zum ersten Mal
mitten in der Urlaubssaison abgestimmt
wird
ein untypischer Wahltag im Juli mit
große Hitze über 36 Grad
so folgt morgen in Spanien ein
untypischer Wahltag auf einen
untypischen Wahlkampf
Madrid wie stehen die Chancen das
Ministerpräsident Sanchez möglicherweise
doch im Amt bleiben könnte
das ist eine Wahl die mit viel
Unsicherheit verbunden ist laut den
letzten Umfragen könnte das morgen ein
knappes Rennen werden da lag Sanchez mit
seiner Partei hinter den konservativen
zurück aber man muss auch sagen dass in
der letzten Woche vor den Wahlen in
Spanien keine aktuellen Umfragen mehr
veröffentlicht werden Petrus Sanchez hat
in den letzten Tagen immer wieder betont
wie gut das Land unter seiner Regierung
wirtschaftlich da steht mit einer
Inflation unter 2%, das ist besser als
in vielen anderen EU-Ländern und mit
einer sinkenden Arbeitslosigkeit
allerdings immer noch auf hohem Niveau
da wünschen sich viele Menschen mehr und
sie werfen ihm auch vor dass er Fehler
gemacht hat in seiner Amtszeit z.B das
neue sexualstraft gesetzt dass den
unerwünschten Nebeneffekt hat hatte dass
Sexualstraftäter früher aus der Haft
entlassen werden konnten und Sanchez hat
auch vor der letzten Wahl versprochen
dass er nicht mit katalanischen
Separatisten und Basten zusammenarbeiten
werde hat es dann aber in der letzten
Zeit doch immer wieder getan also auch
das könnte weder verprellt haben es sind
sehr komplexe Themen die hier den
Wahlkampf und die Wahl morgen bestimmen
aber es wird auf jeden Fall ein sehr
spannender weiter hier morgen in Madrid
danke schön
aus Madrid
in Israel treibt die Regierung von
premier netanjahudi umstrittene
Justizreform voran ab morgen soll sich
das Parlament mit weiten Teilen des
Gesetzes beschäftigen die Menschenmenge
die schon seit Dienstag aus Protest in
Richtung Jerusalem zieht wächst weiter
an inzwischen sollen es mehr als 10.000
Teilnehmer sein sie befürchten dass
durch die Justizreform die
Gewaltenteilung geschwächt wird
[Musik]
vor kurzem galten Wärmepumpen noch als
heiß begehrte Mangelware doch angesichts
hoher Strompreise und der Verunsicherung
ums heizungsgesetz ist die Nachfrage
stark zurückgegangen die Entwicklung
seit dramatisch fürs Klima und für
Unternehmen warnen Verbraucher und
klimaschutzverbände wer jetzt auf die
klimafreundliche Technik setzt muss
erstens nicht lange warten und kann
zweitens sogar von Rabatten profitieren
Christina igelseder
im Moment haben die Heizungsbauer hier
in der Nähe von München noch jede Menge
zu tun aber neue Aufträge für
Wärmepumpen kommen kaum noch rein die
Firma hat sich da ja entschlossen die
Preise für den Einbau zu senken räumt
Neukunden Rabatte ein von bis zu 2000
Euro wir merken auf jeden Fall dass auch
jetzt schon Kunden Aufträge zurückziehen
was gar nicht nur an der neuen Förderung
sondern auch einfach eine generellen
Unsicherheit liegt die dieser hin und
her mit der Gesetzgebung jetzt
verursacht hat die Nachfrage
eingebrochen im August wurde die
bisherige staatliche Förderung
zurückgefahren danach haben sich die
Anträge im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr
nahezu halbiert
noch arbeiten die Hersteller die alten
Aufträge ab 5 Milliarden Euro hat die
Branche in den Aufbau der Produktion
gesteckt befürchtet nun dass sich der
negative Trend verfestigt die
Verschiebung des neuen Gebäude
Energiegesetzes macht ihnen sorgen das
war eventuell zu viele Mitarbeiter
aufbauen oder zu wenig Mitarbeiter
aufbauen und dann wieder in
Lieferschwierigkeiten kommen und das
bedeutet dass wir bei unserer
Liquiditätsplanung sehr genau hingucken
müssen ist macht uns das Leben etwas
schwieriger der Absatz von Öl und
Gasheizungen dagegen hat sich zurzeit
fast verdoppelt viele Verbraucher
erneuern Sie noch schnell setzen noch
nicht auf die energetisch sinnvollere
aber hochpreisige Wärmepumpe zurzeit
kann man tatsächlich nur abwarten
empfehlen bis sich die politische Lage
klärt und man auch genauer weiß wie die
ökonomischen Randbedingungen sind
Wärmepumpen gelten als beste Lösung um
den CO2-Ausstoß beim Heizen zu
verringern doch das Ziel der
Bundesregierung 500.000 Geräte pro Jahr
scheint jetzt in weiter Ferne
Freiwilligendienste wie das Soziale Jahr
sind beliebt und gelten als wichtiges
ehrenamtliches Engagement trotzdem will
die Bundesregierung künftig dafür
weniger Geld ausgeben statt wie in
diesem Jahr 326 Millionen Euro sollen es
2024 nur noch
248 Millionen sein das würde zum Verlust
von bis zu 30.000 Plätzen führen und
wäre verheerend für Hilfsbedürftige und
das Gemeinwesen während der Paritätische
Wohlfahrtsverband
vor zwei Wochen eskalierte beim
sogenannten eritrea-festival in Gießen
die Gewalt Gegner des Festivals das dem
diktatorischen Regime in Eritrea nahe
stehen sollen lieferten sich brutale
Auseinandersetzungen mit der Polizei 26
Beamte wurden verletzt 130 Menschen
festgenommen in Hanau haben sich jetzt
Vertreter der Opposition zu einer
Konferenz getroffen im Vorfeld kam es
wieder zu Ausschreitungen Isabella
ein Restaurant im Frankfurter
Gallusviertel Spuren eines politischen
Konfliktes der seine Wurzeln in Afrika
hat am späten Abend überfallen 20 Männer
das Lokal und zerstören das Mobiliar
geschaut und nur gesehen wie Leute
gekommen sind maskierte Leute schwarz
weiße Masken politische Gegner des
Regimes in Eritrea sollen hier zur Abend
gegessen haben ihnen habe der Angriff
gegolten das glaubt Ruth bachter eine
Aktivistin die die Diktatur in Eritrea
immer wieder kritisiert
es gibt auch jetzt zum Beispiel in dem
aktuell nach Gießen war das so dass man
auch das auch viele junge Leute
angerufen worden sind von ähm von
bestimmten Leuten die dann gesagt haben
ja wir bringen euch um wenn ihr euch
weiter aktiv einsetzten das ist doch
hier auf einem internationalen Kongress
gegen die Diktatur in Eritrea immer noch
Thema vor zwei Wochen hatten junge
Regime-Gegner in Gießen Polizisten
verletzt als sie gegen einen Festival
demonstrierten an dem Vertreter der
eritreischen Regierung teilnahmen wir
sind auch gegen Gewalt das wollen wir
nicht wir wollen aber auch dass die
deutsche Regierung oder auch die
deutsche Mehrheitsgesellschaft damals
drauf schaut und genau guckt was
passiert da eigentlich innerhalb der
europäischen Community und dagegen auch
Maßnahmen einleite zum Beispiel dieses
Eritrea Festival verbietet viele der
jungen Regime-Gegner sind nach
Deutschland geflohen weil sie nicht ins
Militär eingezogen werden wollten
das Regime mit Eritrea verpflichtet alle
erwachsenen Männer wie Frauen
Zwangsdienst zu leisten und zwar
entweder
Arbeitsdienst in allen möglichen
Bereichen oder Militärdienst
vor Gewalt zu fliehen und in dem Land
das ihnen Schutz bietet Polizisten
anzugreifen das stößt auf viel Kritik
der sie sich weiter stellen müssen
Temperaturen von fast 40 Grad und drüber
die Hitzewelle in Griechenland will
nicht enden auf Rhodos ist ein großer
Waldbrand außer Kontrolle geraten
hunderte Touristen mussten mit Bussen
und Booten der Küstenwache in Sicherheit
gebracht werden die Rauchbildung sei so
stark dass man kaum atmen könne so der
Vizebürgermeister der Insel starke
windefachen die Feuer immer wieder ab
und dieses Wochenende könnte in
Griechenland sogar das heißeste
Juliwochenende seit 50 Jahren werden 43
Grad sind morgen in Athen prognostiziert
da ist für alle weiterhin schwitzen
angesagt gefragt jede Art der Abkühlung
Ab in den Süden da sagen einige nein
Danke und fahren zum Durchschnaufen und
urlauben lieber ab in den Norden Heike
Kruse
seit Tagen schon Schauer Wind
Temperaturen um die 20 Grad aber immer
wieder auch Sonne das ist der typische
Schleswig-Holstein Sommer die Urlauber
im Ostseebad Laboe vermissen die
mittelmeerhitze nicht die Temperaturen
sind angenehmer
es ist nicht so weit
und wir haben Fischbrötchen in dem Süden
bis sagst du ja nur Hitze und nur in
schattenschleppen und das ist auch nicht
das Ding 40 Grad muss nicht haben 20 25
Grad reicht aus
am Nord und Ostsee läuft die Hochsaison
gut lautes Dachverbands europäischer
Tourismusorganisationen sind die
Buchungen für Südeuropa in diesem Sommer
um 10% gesunken ein Trend für die
Zukunft es sind schöne marginale
Marktanteile die sich jetzt verschieben
die die großen Verschiebungen werden
noch auf uns zukommen wir müssen uns
auch bewusst sein dass in anderen
Jahreszeiten ja sich die Situation
vielleicht an den Mittelmeerländern
verbessert es wird dann im Winter
attraktiver Viertel Mittelmeerländer
vielleicht entdecken nun auch mehr
Touristen aus Südeuropa den
norddeutschen Sommer ein mögliches
Zukunftsszenario
selbstverständlich wird es auch im
Norden Deutschlands wärmer werden in den
nächsten Jahren ganz Deutschland hat
sich ja schon aufgeheizt um zwei Grad
bisher und das wird sich weiter
fortsetzen und da ist der Norden nicht
ausgenommen
kommende Woche soll das kühle
Schauerwetter an der deutschen Küste
noch bleiben Nord und Ostsee die
Alternative zur Hitze im Süden
wir sind hier nicht zum Spaß Christopher
Street Day in der Hauptstadt heute doch
all die Fröhlichkeit und schrillen
Kostüme können nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass sich etwas verändert
hat die Atmosphäre sei homophober
geworden sagte gerade Hape Kerkeling bei
Maybrit Illner er habe deshalb mit
seinem Mann schweren Herzens Berlin
verlassen und sei nach Köln
zurückgezogen wie die Feiernden heute
die Stimmung erleben zeigt Nils
Schneider
einmal im Jahr in der Mehrheit sein
Thomas und Florian genießen die
CSD-Parade in Berlin so fröhlich und
friedlich ist die Stadt nicht immer
Ortswechsel hier auf der Yorckstraße
wurden die beiden letztes Jahr
angegriffen als die Hand in Hand liefen
sprangen drei Männer aus einem Auto und
fingen an zu pöbeln
das wurde körperlich also du bist
bespuckt worden
und ich danach ebenfalls bespuckt und er
ist auf mich zu und hat mir halt in mit
der Faust ins Gesicht geschlagen das war
auch eine gewaltexplosion die die ich
selbst so in meinem Leben noch nicht
erlebt habe es war wirklich so von Null
auf 200 die Angriffe auf die quiere
Gemeinschaft nehmen zu im letzten Jahr
wurden in Berlin 542 Straftaten
angezeigt die hauptstadtpolizei erfasst
das als einzige in Deutschland
statistisch in vier Jahren hat sich die
Zahl verdoppelt früher waren sie mehr
Beleidigungen die angezeigt worden sind
und jetzt sind wir tatsächlich ein sehr
schweren Körperverletzungen also
wirklich massive Übergriffe auf Trans
Menschen insbesondere und auf die Schule
Community die Täter sind fast
ausnahmslos Männer darunter welche mit
Migrationshintergrund oder christlich
fundamentalen Ansichten die statistisch
größte Gruppe hat rechtsradikale Motive
und die versuchen ja nicht nur unsere
Rechte uns wieder zu nehmen uns mundtot
zu machen sondern die wollen uns dass
der Gesellschaft ganz raus haben und das
ist bedenklich Thomas und Florian ist es
übrigens gelungen während des Angriffs
die Polizei zu rufen die Beamten konnten
die Täter festnehmen im September
beginnt der Prozess
und jetzt Fußball-WM da hatten die
Titelverteidigerin aus den USA einen
lockeren Start ja also die wirken
wirklich fest entschlossen beim 9
Turnier zum fünften Mal zu triumphieren
mit einem ungefährdeten 13:0 gegen
Vietnam gelingt dem US-Team in Auckland
ein
souveränerauftakt-spielerinnen ganz
besonders genossen haben
Kapitän in Lindsey Horan links und
Sophia Smith feiern sich und einen
glanzvollen Auftritt Horan Alex Morgan
per Hacke Smith vollendet 1:0 nach 14
Minuten Alex morgen die Torjägerin des
US-Teams in der 44 Minute ohne Erfolg
trotz Elfmeter in der Nachspielzeit der
ersten Hälfte das 2:0 für die
Amerikanerinnen wieder Sophia Smith
Glück gehört eben auch dazu ich bin mit
der Einstellung des Spiel gegangen dem
Team zu helfen was immer auch dafür
nötig ist das hat geklappt und ich bin
glücklich darüber zu wissen wo wir jetzt
stehen sie ist die Spielerin des menschs
zwei Tore eine Torvorlage und die ist
für ihn sie holen zum 13.0 entstand die
USA treffen kommenden Mittwoch auf die
Niederlande WM Endspiel Gegner 2019
für Europameister England gab es im
ersten Spiel wenig zu jubeln wenn man
von Georgia stanways erfolgreich im
Strafstoß absieht Außenseite Haiti
leistete beim knappen 0:1 sind starke
Gegenwehr
bis zur 25 Minute beide Teams auf
Augenhöhe Ecke für England und Proteste
der Spielerin denn bei cheval Lewis
berührt den Ball mit der Hand Elfmeter
für England doch Haitis Torhüterin Mary
earths verlässt vor dem Schuss die
Grundlinie der Videobeweis entscheidet
Wiederholung also im zweiten Anlauf das
1:0 durch Georgia stanway von Bayern
München die Engländerin auch in der
zweiten Halbzeiten nicht dominant in der
81 Minute hat Bruce Lyn elisor sogar die
Möglichkeit zum Ausgleich doch Mary
Earth pariert sehenswert und rettet den
Auftrag Sieg verlangt
in der Gruppe D ist Dänemark mit England
gleich auf durch das 1:0 der Dänen gegen
China und in Gruppe C hat Japan durch
das klare 5:0 gegen Sambia die
Tabellenführung von Spanien übernommen
Stichwort Sambia bei der Niederlage im
letzten Testspiel gab es ja drei
Gegentreffer durch die
nordafrikanerinnen durch die
Afrikanerinnen für Deutschland noch
bastelt Bundestrainerin Martina fast
Tecklenburg mit ihrem Team an der
Abwehrformation vor dem Auftakt am
Montag gegen Marokko
so langsam schließt sich der Kreis für
die DFB-Frauen ein letztes Training in
der Abgeschiedenheit des teamquartiers
vor dem Abflug Richtung auftaktspielort
das ist zwar eine lange Zeit wir fühlen
uns sehr gut vorbereitet auf den Gegner
Marokko und wir freuen uns einfach dass
es morgen für uns mit der Anreise
losgeht und dann Montag dass wir endlich
auf den Platz dürfen
Abwehrchefin Marina Hegering exklusiv
von unserer Kamera gefilmt erstmals
wieder am Ball aber dem Verletzung
Sorgenkind bleibt wohl nur die
Zuschauerrolle bei ihnen
Verteidigerinnen Ersatz Joke Nüsken
macht das rechte Knieprobleme klickt
nach Viererkette mit der Frankfurterin
Sarah dort zu wenn ich gebraucht werde
bin ich da und ich habe die Erfahrung
dass man mich auch ins kalte Wasser
schmeißen kann spätestens am Montag
findet das personelle Versteckspiel ein
Ende
diese Jubelpose kann man sich schon für
morgen merken Jonas wingegord wird wenn
nichts völlig außergewöhnliches passiert
am Sonntag wie im Vorjahr die Tour de
France gewinnen im Zielraum in Le Marc
Stein in den Vogesen konnte der Däne im
kleinen Familienkreis schon mal vor
feiern nach einer in der Schlussphase
spektakulären Etappe im direkten Duell
mit dem zweimaligen tursieger Tadday
pugatscha rechts im Bild und der Slowene
setzte sich im Sprint gegen den
Österreicher Felix Gall und den Mann in
gelb aus Dänemark durch morgen dann noch
die gewohnten Ehrenrunden auf den See
und heute schon schöne Familienbilder
vielen Dank morgen wird's im Nordwesten
regnerisch und windig im Südosten
dagegen zeigt sich häufig die Sonne
Details hat gleich Christa Augen
Christian Sievers begrüßt sie ihm heute
journal um viertel 11:15 Uhr und hier
übernimmt morgen jana pareig ist das
gesamte heute Team sagt danke und
tschüss und wünscht Ihnen ein schönes
Wochenende auf bald
[Musik]
ja guten Abend im Südosten da bleibt es
morgen mit diesem Hoch hermiona hier
etwas sommerlicher im Nordwesten
allerdings werden wohl eher
herbstgefühle aufkommen denn da zieht
tief Unai mit seinen Freunden mit Wolken
und Regen über uns hinweg und zudem auch
mit Wind der schon heute Nacht an der
Nordsee aus Südwest auffrischt der Regen
jetzt im Norden der verstärkt sich in
der Nacht noch mal etwas Richtung Süden
werden die Wolken aber weniger dann ist
der Himmel auch mal klar da singen die
Werte auf zehn sonst auf 17 bis 12 Grad
Morgen sind die Temperaturen dann ganz
klar zweigeteilt im Nordwesten gibt es
18 bis 22 Grad im Südosten aber noch mal
25 bis 30 Grad und im Süden scheint dazu
auch noch viel die Sonne Richtung Norden
werden die Wolken aber häufiger es gibt
mehr Regen der Schwerpunkt liegt auf
Nordfriesland da sind bis morgen Abend
40 Liter pro Quadratmeter möglich aber
auch im Westen mit der Kaltfront kannst
du zeitweise mal kräftiger regnen und
dazu gibt's diesen lebhaften Wind der in
höheren Lagen und auch im Umfeld der
Nordsee für stürmische böhnen sorgen
kann
am Montag beschäftigt uns das Tief
weiter dann lokal mit Unwettern ab
Dienstag wird dann überall nur mäßig
warm auch im Südosten mit um 20 Grad und
wir müssen uns um Hitze und fehlende
Regen in den nächsten Tagen erst mal
keine Gedanken machen tschüss